buddhist monks were among the many
marching in yangon
they led prayers outside the u.s embassy
to call for the release of anseong tsu
chi
and other civilian leaders
we just want our country to escape from
under the military dictatorship to be
peaceful and developed
we don't want to go back to the darkest
era before 2010
we want peace and we are against the
military dictatorship
moore marched in the capital napieda
joining thousands for an eighth day of
protests
which denounce night time raids against
coup opponents
while a curfew is in place from 8 pm
until 4 am local time
people have been out and on edge
neighborhood watch groups do their best
to warn when police are coming
in some cases they turn away to avoid
confrontation
in others people are taken away
a local watchdog group for political
prisoners says the raids are targeting
dissenting voices
a lot of us us you know we were involved
in the
democracy movement in the past are
on like a high alert like we we
activated our safety protocols and uh we
don't even sleep in one place we move
one after another
and a lot of activists even though they
are not arrested are concerned that
they may be targeted next the u.n human
rights council has called on the junta
to release all who've been arbitrarily
detained
the army responded on saturday by
suspending laws requiring court orders
to detain
suspects for more than a day for
searching private property
and surveillance more than 350 people
have been arrested since the coup on
february 1st
the military also shot peaceful
protesters related the ruling party's
offices
and confiscated documents records and
property
moreover it placed restrictions on
people's freedom of speech
by preparing a telecommunications bill
intended to control access
to the internet and mobile services as
state tv channels broadcast pictures of
vandalism and attacks on police vehicles
the head of the military general minh
clang has been on the airwaves repeating
allegations
of voter fraud in last november's
parliamentary elections
more errors have been found in the voter
rolls he says the nation must join hands
with the military
for the successful realization of
democracy as protests grow in size and
begin to affect its flow of cash
the military is about to give itself
even more powers a cyber security law
that human rights watch calls the dream
of despots everywhere
making protests more difficult to
organize and the pictures of them
riskier to share andrew chappelle al
jazeera